[Musique]
à
granby et bébé il était très moche mais
là il s'améliore wade a de la chance tu
as vu mon sens le pas on est content oui
non il est mignon par contre ils avaient
rappelé au trophée des villes
il aime qu'on applaudisse quand il fait
caca puis sur des trucs très sainte foy
il essaie de mettre des rebonds dernier
carré ou alors c'est peut-être un
surdoué qu'il est con oui certainement
intel compte des goûts tiens regarde une
vidéo on voit qui marche c'est ouf non
non c'est pourri ne fait deux pas il est
tombé et a pas monté les vrais sont plus
là je crois que le petit effet dans sa
couche
non non non c'est moi c'est pas le motif
est désolé ça que je pensais qu'il me
couvrir m&a c'est assez faible
on sait moins chaud en tout cas nous on
attend un peu mais on veut faire un
deuxième vous et compliquent ont déjà un
buzz est au bout du rouleau tasse pour
les impôts et puis c'est les enfants
c'est un peu comme les chats de ils
s'amusent beaucoup plus
toi t'as pas envie d'en avoir si bien
sûr cool mais quand je vois plus du tout
vivement qu'ils rentrent à l'internât là
on a hâte
ben oui qu'ils apprennent plein de
choses et tout ça mais ça on s'en fout
je vais enfin pouvoir m'occuper de moi
jusque là ça fait un an et demi que je
me suis pas épilée c'est la forêt cadel
et on va foncer à bosse week-end chez
moi aussi je veux venir ce serait top
oui avec plaisir sur cool ailleurs
l'enfant banon allemands n'ont visé pour
être lever à 7h du matin va pouvoir
sortir parce qu'il fait des siestes les
bouffer à 18 heures je suis pas vraiment
une
par contre si vous voulez spectre on
peut louer une maison dans le sud mais
sans enfant oui
à la cool pas bons on applaudissait son
caca épuisé
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]